[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MANDEL: Hi, and
welcome to episode number
150 of the weekly Google
Cloud Platform Podcast.
I'm Mark Mandel.
And I'm here, as always,
with my colleague, Melanie.
How are you doing, Melanie?
MELANIE WARRICK: Hi, Mark.
I'm good.
How are you?
MARK MANDEL: I'm very well.
MELANIE WARRICK: What--
MARK MANDEL: It's
good to see you again.
MELANIE WARRICK:
--episode is this?
MARK MANDEL: This is 150.
MELANIE WARRICK: 150--
I know, it's amazing, right?
[FIREWORKS]
MARK MANDEL: I know.
I was actually
trying to work out
when you first came
on the podcast,
and I couldn't work it out.
MELANIE WARRICK: I
started helping you
at the beginning of November.
So we're almost at a year.
MARK MANDEL: We're
almost at a year.
That's pretty good.
You've put up with
me for a year.
MELANIE WARRICK: I know,
it's kind of amazing.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: And it's been
almost three years since you
started the podcast.
MARK MANDEL: It's true.
Your first episode
you came on was 93--
"What's AI with
Melanie Warrick."
MELANIE WARRICK: True,
y'all did interview me.
But I actually started
helping you in November
when Francesc took off.
Anyway, so Mark, what do
we have for this week?
MARK MANDEL: So we have some
cool stuff for this week.
We have a very good
mutual friend of ours,
KF, who has a long history
of working in the software
engineering industry,
doing distributed systems,
and kind of all the
things, I feel like,
and is the reason we know
each other in the first place
as well.
MELANIE WARRICK: Exactly.
She's definitely the
reason we know each other.
And it's an interview
that I've been wanting
us to do for a while now.
So I'm really glad we finally
got a chance to talk to her.
And we were able to
do that, actually,
at a conference where
we did meet also,
which is Strange Loop, a
great conference that's
out of St. Louis.
So we'll get into
that in the interview.
But yeah, I'm glad we
finally got a chance
to get her on here.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, exactly.
And so after we
talk to her, we will
have our question of the
week, as we do always,
which is, how do I
encrypt and decrypt data
with Cloud Key Management
Services, which is something
I've not looked at before.
But it's actually kind of cool.
MELANIE WARRICK: Definitely.
And as we always do,
we're going to start out
with cool things of the week.
And for this week, we've got a
lot of support and integration
going on with PyTorch,
which is a platform that's
used for building out neural
nets, similar to TensorFlow.
It's just a different platform.
And so PyTorch, we
now have integrated.
So there's actually, on
Google Cloud Platform,
deep learning VM images
that you can implement.
It's also been integrated
already in Kubeflow.
But there's additional support,
specifically because PyTorch
has also launched 1.0.
So you can use that on GSP.
You can use it with Kubeflow.
You can use it, actually,
also with TensorBoard.
And there's work in progress.
They're piloting some
stuff around the cloud TPUs
and using PyTorch.
So we'll post the article for
that, and you can check it out.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
Since we're talking about
Kubeflow and Kubernetes,
we will want to mention a
wonderful little article
called "A developer onramp
to Kubernetes with GKE."
I thought this is really nice
in that it's a set of tools
specifically for making
it easier and more
affordable to run small
Kubernetes clusters, basically
up to four nodes-- or less
than four nodes, if you want.
So if you're trying to set up
a small developer environment,
we actually have some
documentation and a developer
template set up as well as
a new open-source utility
called kubehost to get around
some of the cost things
that happen with Kubernetes.
It can be a little bit
more expensive if you
want to run a big cluster.
So this is just
some nice tooling
to get you started in
a nice, low-cost way.
MELANIE WARRICK: And
another cool thing
of the week we want to
mention is "Network controls
in GCP vs. on-premises."
This is a blog post that our
friend Grace has posted in--
MARK MANDEL: Oh, it's Grace.
MELANIE WARRICK: --conjunction
with Jens Kuehlers, which
I'm probably botching the name.
But this article
in particular is
sort of walking you
through the fact
that network controls in
GCP are not that different,
necessarily, from on-premises.
So you wouldn't have to
do a significant amount
of additional
understanding, I guess,
or work, to understand the two.
And they talk through subnets,
and routes, and firewalls,
and VPN.
MARK MANDEL: Yep, and
last, definitely not least,
I feel like every
time we turn around,
there's a new article by
our teammate Sara Robinson.
I don't know if that's
the way you feel.
MELANIE WARRICK: I do too.
She's definitely producing
a lot of good content--
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
it's really great.
MELANIE WARRICK: --on AutoML.
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely.
So she has another great
article talking about AutoML.
But in this case, it's talking
about AutoML Translate, which
is really kind of interesting.
It talks about how and
why you might need AutoML
power translate capabilities.
So the example that they
use is like, for example,
using the word "driver."
Like, if you're playing golf,
"driver" means one thing.
But if you need a taxi,
"driver" means something else.
But if you're in a
software context,
"driver" means
yet another thing.
And so you might need
something like AutoML
to be able to do translations
that are domain-specific.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes, and she
steps you through an example
that she spelt out specifically
with AutoML Translate,
and also using something
known as Welocalize,
which is-- it's one of
the largest localization
providers in the
US with a mission
to help the customers localize
content for global audiences.
So you can check out
her article and see how
to use Google AutoML Translate.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Well, why don't we go
have a chat with KF?
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes, we should
definitely go talk with KF.
MARK MANDEL: It'll be fun.
MELANIE WARRICK: I'm very
happy we have with us, today,
KF, who is a good
friend of both of ours
and is the reason why Mark and
I actually know each other.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
MELANIE WARRICK:
So, KF, thank you
very much for coming
on the podcast today.
KF: Sure, hi.
[LAUGHTER]
MELANIE WARRICK: Hi.
MARK MANDEL: Hey.
MELANIE WARRICK: So KF, tell us
a little bit about who you are.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
what do you do?
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes,
and why do we know you?
KF: I do computers vaguely.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
KF: I do some combination
of, like, back end, and data,
and infrastructure things,
primarily at startups.
MELANIE WARRICK: And
data science things.
KF: I would not describe
myself as a data scientist.
MELANIE WARRICK: That's fair.
KF: I would describe myself as
an engineer with a math degree.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
MELANIE WARRICK: We were noting,
before we start recording,
you did hold the title, at
one point, of data scientist.
KF: I'm not sure that
startup titles count.
MELANIE WARRICK: This is
a good way to get started.
So we're recording
this at Strange Loop.
Strange Loop is this conference.
It's actually where I
met Mark, because of KF.
And I met KF because we both
went through the same coding
bootcamp--
not together, but we met because
of it, which was really great.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, you went
through at different times.
I did not know that.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
But anyway, so KF, how's the
conference going for you?
KF: It's good.
It is mostly-- this is
my sixth year coming.
So every time I come back,
it's like fewer and fewer talks
I go to the conference
and more just sort
of walking around,
attempting to go to a talk
as people stop me on the way.
MELANIE WARRICK: And actually,
what is Strange Loop?
KF: I don't really know.
I think when I
started coming, it
was mostly because
there were talks
on functional programming.
And that is not necessarily
the talks I go to now at all.
MARK MANDEL: I feel like
it's like this weird mix
of bleeding-edge-ish computer
science, wacky interesting tech
stuff, philosophy,
diversity, inclusion,
social, political issues mushed
into one big thing that seems
like it's cool and interesting.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah, and it's
been going on for 10 years.
Alex, who's the original--
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: --person you
drove and developed all this,
he's doing a little
retrospective back
on when it started.
I think it was like 300
people at the first one.
And now it's around
2,200 people--
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: --for this
one, yeah, based in St. Louis.
So you don't know,
but you love it.
And you got a good network here.
What were some of the highlights
from today and yesterday
so far for you?
KF: I spent most of the
past day and a half going
to talks about tech related
to social good, which is not
something that they had
talks on whenever I first
started coming.
It was more in recent years,
given the political atmosphere,
that these started
being introduced.
So Bridget, who's one
of the other organizers,
who I know from
doing Clojure stuff,
she put together a
pre-conference day that was
the whole day yesterday that
was on people who work on tools
related to nonprofits and
helping the government--
MARK MANDEL: Oh, cool.
KF: --and environmental
issues, and things like that.
MARK MANDEL: Any
cool stuff that we
could take away and
potentially tell our listeners?
KF: I think the most
actionable talk was probably
the one from the guy who
started Ruby for Good.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, cool.
KF: Gave to talk about
how to get more involved
with nonprofits and why
you should do that--
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
KF: --in your spare time--
like, instead of just doing
open source related to
things that are technically
interesting, doing
open source related
to things that are
useful to people outside
of the tech industry.
MELANIE WARRICK: You went to
that talk-- oh, never mind.
MARK MANDEL: I did not.
I wasn't here yesterday.
KF: In spirit, not physically.
MARK MANDEL: No.
MELANIE WARRICK: You went to a
different talk on open source.
That was today.
MARK MANDEL: I did.
Evan, who started Elm,
whose last name I can never
pronounce, did a
really interesting talk
on dealing with being an
open source maintainer
and dealing with people
coming up and being like,
Elm is going to die.
And like, how do you handle that
as an open source maintainer,
but also actions that can be
taken to potentially turn that
into a more positive
statement and codify
the sort of
conversations that should
happen inside that environment.
And he tied it back
to a whole bunch
of philosophical and
sociological stuff that
came previously with books
about that kind of stuff
that come from the
'60s and stuff.
It was actually really,
really good talk.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
Mark, what got you starting
to come to Strange Loop?
MARK MANDEL: I used to come
here from Australia regularly,
I think, about six years ago.
MELANIE WARRICK: Wow, so
you've been here for six years
as well?
MARK MANDEL:
Something like that.
I think I missed a year
somewhere in between.
I'm trying to remember.
I think I had a friend who
was coming, or I saw it.
And I was like, that
just looks awesome,
and I need to be
at that conference.
And so I started, I think,
is the short answer.
And then I was like,
this is amazing.
I need to come back.
It's a conference that
imposes imposter syndrome.
[LAUGHTER]
Like, it doesn't--
MELANIE WARRICK: That sounds
really inspiring for people
to come.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, I know.
But I feel like it's true.
Because it is an environment
in which you're always
going to meet someone who
knows stuff you don't know.
Or you're just going
to sit in a talk
and just be like, I have
no idea what that is.
But I feel like, two
years down the line,
if you head in a
certain direction,
depending on what it
is, you'll be like,
oh, I remember that
talk from Strange Loop
two years ago that I saw
about someone talking
about something.
Now I know how to make
mathematical models that'll
tell me how to
fold origami paper.
Like, awesome, I can use that.
[GONG]
MELANIE WARRICK: And
did you make that?
MARK MANDEL: I have
not needed that yet.
But I assume, at some
point, that I will.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Someday, you will.
OK, well, if it's imposing
the imposter syndrome,
why are you both
coming back so often?
KF: I don't know that I
have imposter syndrome.
[LAUGHTER]
I think I just tend to see
working in the tech industry
as being like in many other
jobs in which you just
have to constantly pick up new
skills, because capitalism.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
I also love to--
I love to learn.
That's a big, deep-seeded
thing that I love, a passion.
MELANIE WARRICK: I know.
I appreciate that
this conference
seems to be very driven to give
conference talks on knowledge
and sharing knowledge
verses, like, we
want to show you the new--
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: --fandangled--
MARK MANDEL: It's
very much not a--
MELANIE WARRICK: --shiny--
MARK MANDEL:
--beginner conference--
MELANIE WARRICK: --thing.
MARK MANDEL: --but,
I think, is still
open to people who are
beginners, either levels
or mindsets.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes.
KF: Whenever I started
coming, I had, like,
no experience programming.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Wait, is that like
realistically or functionally?
KF: No, like realistically, I
had no experience programming.
I had, like, three months
of experience programming
or something ridiculous.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, I'd never
done functional programming
before or touched anything
that had been mentioned
at Strange Loop before I came.
KF: In the first
year I came, it was
before they had opportunity
grants and things.
MELANIE WARRICK: Which is
one of the things I've always
been very impressed with.
With this conference
in particular,
there's been such a drive,
specifically with opportunity
grants, and just making
sure that the diversity is
being recognized and built out.
And if anything, I've seen
that evolve and change.
It's such a small
thing, but it's so true.
Like, last year
was the first time
I saw a line at the
women's bathroom.
And it was the first
time I've ever seen
a line at the women's bathroom.
I was like, oh, that's awesome.
Any other highlights from
the conference this year,
previous years?
Like, did you all meet
at this conference?
MARK MANDEL: How did we meet?
KF: We met through our mutual
friend Sean, who you know
from when you did ColdFusion--
[LAUGHTER]
MARK MANDEL: That
sounds about right.
That sounds about
right, actually.
KF: --and who I know through
things unrelated to ColdFusion.
MARK MANDEL: You weren't a
ColdFusion programmer too?
Actually, to your
point-- like, we
were talking about
why I was here.
I feel like-- and if we want
to go back through my history,
because I don't know why.
That seems like a
thing we're doing now--
I think it was around
the time that I'd
stopped doing
ColdFusion as a thing
and was really trying
to expand my horizons
and learn a whole
bunch of stuff.
And Strange Loop looked
like an amazing opportunity
to do that, and honestly,
continues to be so.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Did Strange Loop
inspire you to get more
exposure to distributed
systems, distributed computing?
KF: I think it sort of
came the other way around,
which is, I got into
programming because I
was in grad school for math.
And for some assignment my
first semester of grad school,
I ended up reading research
papers from the Google research
website, and was
reading something
about clustering algorithms
at YouTube or something,
and was like, oh,
this is interesting,
and then tried to learn
to program and stuff,
and then ended up
going to Code School.
And then once I
was there, people
were like, you seem to
be the kind of person who
enjoys academic papers,
which means, probably,
functional programming
and distributed systems
are for you.
MELANIE WARRICK: And
then you went with it?
KF: Yeah-- not necessarily a
normal start into programming.
MELANIE WARRICK: What is a
normal start into programming?
KF: I do know that when I
started out doing programming
and could cite a bunch
of academic papers
but had no experience
in industry,
that was deeply unusual.
And people did not know
how to respond to it.
I think it's less bizarre
now, in part, I think,
because they have things
like Strange Loop that
have opportunity grants.
So it's not unheard of.
MARK MANDEL: Do you
recommend it as a pathway?
MELANIE WARRICK: That's
a great question.
KF: Recommend is a strong word.
I would say follow
your bliss also though.
I don't think it's harder,
from a technical perspective,
to pick up these things.
There's nothing inherent about
this area of computer science
or software
engineering that I feel
is harder than doing
front end, for example.
I think that sometimes people
make it artificially harder,
because they think it's harder.
So they don't
bother to learn how
to talk about things in a
way that's more approachable
versus, does there
exist something that
teaches distributed
systems to beginners
in a systematic way like the
way that there's Girls Who Code.
And what are the
nonprofit, like--
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
KF: There are so many though, at
this point, where they teach--
MELANIE WARRICK: I
know what you mean.
KF: There are so many places--
MARK MANDEL: The variety.
KF: --where you can--
yes, the variety--
MELANIE WARRICK: Where you can--
KF: --of all these--
MELANIE WARRICK: You can learn--
KF: --workshop series.
MELANIE WARRICK:
--to build a website.
You can learn how to build a--
KF: Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: --a machine
learning application.
You haven't seen anything yet
that's been introductory to--
KF: No, I don't
think people see it
as being introductory
at all, in part
because nobody writes
introductory materials.
MELANIE WARRICK: Where does
distributed computing typically
sit within the structure
of an engineering org
from what you've seen and
what you've experienced?
KF: I tend to get bounced around
between back end infrastructure
platform-type teams.
And then I sort of fell
into doing data things
for a few years,
like off and on.
Because a lot of
the languages that I
was using to do platform-type
stuff were also starting to get
used for data stuff.
So like Scala, originally, I
picked up not for data stuff.
I picked it up primarily
because functional programming
and distributed systems.
And then that started becoming
a language, because of Spark,
that people were using for data.
So then people
looked at my resume
and were like, you
do data things,
because you have a
math degree and know
these languages, which is not
necessarily accurate, though it
is now.
MELANIE WARRICK: That's kind
of how it works in general.
But I remember, at
one point, you also--
you've had a passion
for Clojure, Clojure
in terms of the functional
programming space.
MARK MANDEL: With a J.
MELANIE WARRICK: I know that's--
yes.
MARK MANDEL: Just making
sure that's clear.
MELANIE WARRICK:
I appreciate that.
KF: Yeah, so I fell into
doing Clojure not for work,
but because I was
on a mailing list.
And Bridget, who's now one of
the co-organizers for Strange
Loop, was putting
together workshops
to teach women Clojure and--
or functional programming
through Clojure.
And before I worked in
tech, I worked in teaching.
So I was sort of like, if you
need any help with curriculum
development, let me know.
And then I got involved
with it through that.
And then eventually,
despite the fact
that I had not written almost
any Clojure in earnest,
I just became very
strongly associated with it
until it was actually
a thing that I did.
MARK MANDEL: So I
also want to know--
I'm very curious about
this answer actually.
[LAUGHTER]
We've said distributed
computing-- you
like disputed systems.
What does that mean to you?
KF: I think that there is a
meaning that it holds for me,
and then there's the meaning
that it holds in industry.
MARK MANDEL: And what's
the-- yeah, what is it?
KF: Because to me, if you're
a front end developer,
you have to have ideas
about distributed
computing at this point.
I think when you talk
to people in industry,
most of the time, what they mean
is you work on core platform
infrastructure-type deals.
MARK MANDEL: Does
that mean Kubernetes?
KF: Amongst other things, sure.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Mark really wants
to bring up the
Kubernetes perspective,
because I believe
there was some stuff
in the history between
the two of the two of you
around Kubernetes.
KF: When I met Mark, he was
still living in Australia,
and did not work for Google--
MARK MANDEL: That's true.
KF: --and had no reason to
shill Kubernetes at the time.
MARK MANDEL: Right.
KF: It wasn't even
necessarily popular--
MARK MANDEL: No.
KF: --at the time.
MELANIE WARRICK: Oh.
MARK MANDEL: But I got--
KF: But he was deeply
enthusiastic in a way
where everybody was like, why
don't you just go and sell
people Kubernetes as your job?
And then he became a
developer relations person
for Kubernetes things.
MELANIE WARRICK:
And here we are.
MARK MANDEL: And here we are.
But now you've actually
used Kubernetes
after giving me grief about
it for a really long time.
KF: Sure.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: And what
do you think of Kubernetes?
KF: And now we've
come full circle.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, yes.
MELANIE WARRICK: And what
do you think of Kubernetes?
KF: I think it's
a tool, and it's
a step in the right direction.
And I think it helps
build better abstractions
in the long term.
I tend to think
about these things
not necessarily
from the perspective
of running infrastructure
for the sake of keeping
things running, but more from
the idea of infrastructure
as a product.
And I think that
it becomes easier
to build those
kinds of tools when
you have something like
Kubernetes that becomes
an abstraction over things.
MELANIE WARRICK: Are there any
other tools that you've found
are valuable in the
work that you do?
KF: I mean, there's Docker,
which is just sort of,
at this point, also
prolific after--
like, it wasn't when I started.
And now after five
years, it's just
like, I can't imagine not
using it at this point.
MELANIE WARRICK: So I
know we've talked around
about the different
things that you've done.
What do you enjoy doing
in the computing space?
KF: I don't know that I enjoy
specific technical things
at this point.
I enjoy building
things that are useful.
MARK MANDEL: That's valid.
Because I think you've had
kind of a history of building
platforms that
would then be on use
by other areas of companies.
Would that be vaguely right?
KF: Yeah.
I haven't done as much
feature development for things
that get used externally.
I've done some of that.
When I work on those
kinds of services,
it's usually more from
an SRE perspective
where I'm trying
to make something
more performant
for the customer,
not necessarily building
the initial thing.
MELANIE WARRICK:
So I know you've
done the coding bootcamp.
You've done some of
your own self-study.
What do you think are
some good pathways now--
and we already talked about some
of the new coding projects that
are out there a little bit in
terms of getting people in.
But what do you think are
some good ways for those
who are trying to find their
pathway into building out
things, building things,
whatever form that takes?
KF: I think all of
the options are hard.
I think there was a
period of time where,
if you already had a degree,
or you couldn't afford
to go to college, then coding
bootcamps were potentially
a really great option if
you chose the right one.
But now they've been around for
so long, and there are so many,
I think it's hard to choose one.
Because there are so many
that are potentially bad.
And there's no
regulation on them.
If you don't have experience
with software engineering
and you maybe don't
know anyone who
does software engineering,
which is the kind of person who
I think would go to
a coding bootcamp,
it's kind of impossible to tell
whether something is snake oil
or not.
So I say that coding bootcamps
exist, and some of them are OK.
And probably check Course
Report, see if it's decent.
There are more places
that are starting
to do apprenticeships,
which I feel
are always the best option.
If you can manage to go
to school for computer
science, that's always, I
think, still the best option.
But that's not really
realistic for everyone.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
KF: It wasn't realistic for me.
MELANIE WARRICK: Well actually,
the keynote this morning
at Strange Loop was talking
about how important it
is for all kids to be exposed to
some type of computer science,
or just basically, something--
MARK MANDEL: Foundational--
MELANIE WARRICK: --around--
MARK MANDEL: --computer
science, yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah,
something along those lines,
as well as trying to give
ideas to think outside the box.
But what do you think
about that in terms
of the education of kids?
Do you think that that's a
skill that definitely needs
to be applied across the board?
KF: I think that everyone
should have exposure
to computer science.
I think some people take
it to a larger degree
and say everyone should have so
many years of computer science
classes or coding
classes in school.
I don't agree that
that's reasonable.
Having worked in schools, it's
like, there's not enough time
already to cover things.
Like, what is the
thing you're going
to take out of the
curriculum to put this in?
I would struggle to think of
something like a core subject,
if you're treating computer
science as a core subject, that
is less important
than learning to code.
I would struggle to
think of something.
MELANIE WARRICK: And
one of the points
they were making this morning
too is how it's hard to find,
also, teachers, specifically
showing some numbers
in terms of there's
less teachers
to be able to provide
the education.
MARK MANDEL: And
the incentives are
aligned for people with
computer science degrees
to not be teachers.
MELANIE WARRICK: Right.
And I was thinking at the time--
I was like, you
could line that up
against those who
have the expertise
in the machine learning space.
And I'm sure it's
even less people.
But I guess the
question I'd ask is--
you've mentored a number of
people coming into the space.
Do you have any
advice for those who
might be thinking about being
mentors, who want to help
others getting into the space?
KF: I think the main
thing is that you should
try to, one, align yourself
with some sort of nonprofit
if you're doing
it systematically.
There are coding bootcamps
that are for profit that
rely very heavily on mentors.
And if the reason
for mentoring people
is to help get more
people into the field,
I don't understand the
rationale for doing that
at a for-profit school.
In the same way that
I will sometimes
go give talks at universities,
to college students,
about computer
science, if I'm going
to sink a bunch of
my time connecting
with some sort of organization
that's providing mentorship
to people, I tend
to go for something
that's low-cost or free.
Because that's usually
people who need it most.
A lot of people I have met
through going to conferences,
or being involved
specifically with setting up
opportunity grant systems,
or volunteering around that.
I don't know that this is advice
for people mentoring so much
as for people who need help with
things, as you'd be surprised
how willing people are to
help you if you just ask them
for it.
Most of the time
people will say yes,
not because I asked for help,
but because people asked me
for help.
And most of the time I say yes.
Or I introduce them to someone
who's more able to help them.
And most of the time,
that person says yes.
MARK MANDEL: I was
going to say, yeah,
have you got any suggestions
for people to find mentors?
I know that's been-- that
can be tricky sometimes.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Just
ask the question?
KF: I'd ask the
question, but also
spend some amount of
time upfront trying
to figure out who the person is
and what they're specialty is.
MARK MANDEL: So
you're not saying
I should just hop on LinkedIn
and spam everyone with emails?
KF: No, that's not
a good approach.
MARK MANDEL: That's not a thing.
KF: It's more like, go to events
in your area if you have them.
If you don't-- every
job I've gotten,
I've gotten through Twitter.
And most of the people who
I know who have spent time
with me teaching me things, a
disproportionately large number
of those people
I met on Twitter.
It's more like, go
socialize with people.
MARK MANDEL: That
seems reasonable.
KF: I'm originally from Houston.
So the advice of,
like, go to events
doesn't apply as strongly
in some cities as in others.
Because there aren't as
many tech events in Houston
as there are even in
Portland, where I live now.
MELANIE WARRICK: Or
start up your own--
MARK MANDEL: That's true.
MELANIE WARRICK: --event.
And start up your own
community if you can.
MARK MANDEL: That takes work,
but yeah, if you've got time.
MELANIE WARRICK:
That's another way.
I know-- I've met a number
of people who have done that.
And I know you and I have talked
about this before, but just
to be on the same page
on this one, the people
you've mentored
especially-- like,
not everybody has a math degree.
Not everybody who's
come into this space
necessarily had much experience
with computer science,
the people that
I've come across,
and I know, for myself, too.
Would you say that's probably
what you've seen as well?
KF: Yeah, most of the time.
MELANIE WARRICK: Because I
know that that can sometimes
be an intimidating factor,
talking about the imposter
syndrome before.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, and
it's probably worth noting,
I mean, amongst our
peers and people
I know, I know a variety
people who have degrees,
but not even remotely
in computer science,
in psychology, in philosophy.
And I know people who are
theater majors, right,
who work in computer science.
KF: My first degree
was in English.
And then I went back to school
later and got a math degree.
MARK MANDEL: Technically, I
have a bachelor in multimedia.
I don't know what
that's worth at all.
SPEAKER 1: I have a film degree.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
KF: It's for making podcasts.
That's what it's for.
MARK MANDEL: That's
what it's for?
It's so I can use
Macromedia Director.
That's what it's for.
MELANIE WARRICK: That
is the only reason why.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Yeah, how did games
come into the middle of this?
Just because you play them.
MARK MANDEL: I play them.
MELANIE WARRICK: So
on a different note,
how do you get
all your work done
with your cat on your head?
[CAT MEOWING]
KF: I work from home.
My cat usually leaves
me alone unless I'm
in meetings is the key thing.
MARK MANDEL: Sounds about right.
MELANIE WARRICK:
How do you make sure
you're successful in what
you're doing working remotely.
Because I know that's something
that you typically do.
KF: Yeah, I've always
worked remotely.
Or for a while, I
worked for a company
that was in Portland
while I lived in Portland,
but just never went
into the office.
I think I started doing remote
stuff from when I was entry
level on, which is unusual.
Because most people aren't
willing to hire people who are
entry level to work remotely.
I think it was mostly
a factor of finding
support systems locally--
or even if not
locally, like now,
all the time, I'll
run into something.
And I won't really know
how to solve the problem.
And I'll be like the tech
lead, so there's no one else
to solve it for me at work.
So I end up going
and talking to people
I just know from the internet--
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
KF: --or people I met in
other cities when I was
at conferences, or
when I lived there,
or when I worked for a
company there and be like--
MARK MANDEL: In your network.
KF: --have you run into this?
Yeah.
And then we do that
for each other.
MARK MANDEL: That's a
really good question too,
in just talking about
remote culture and something
I've-- like you've said people
don't like to hire people who
are at entry level
for remote positions.
What's a successful
way of bringing
in entry-level people for
remote positions, do you think?
KF: I don't think it's a
requirement that people have
previous professional
experience to work remotely
as part of their first job.
Because I've worked with
entry-level people who
had never really
had a job before
and were remote in other
time zones, other countries,
and it worked out fine.
I do think, though, that it
is helpful to set them up
with a specific person who
can walk them through--
MARK MANDEL: Like a
one-on-one mentor.
KF: --what that looks like.
Yeah, you should do that anyway
when someone is starting a job,
but even more so
with remote stuff,
especially if you can
find someone who's
been doing remote for a while.
And it helps to be very explicit
about what your day looks like
and what other people's
days look like.
So when I started
working remotely,
I did not actually have
industry experience.
Before that, I'd only
ever worked in schools.
So I did not understand what it
was like to work in an office.
MARK MANDEL: Right.
KF: So I had this--
I didn't understand
that there were
times of the day when people
went up to go get coffee,
or walk down the street
to get coffee even.
And that was like a
20-minute break right there.
So I had this
weird notion that I
needed to be sitting at
my computer all the time--
MELANIE WARRICK: Oh, wow.
KF: --or like-- and I
needed to put it, like,
eight hours a day.
And I also worked
freelance for a while--
like eight hours a day of
earnest coding, not working,
which--
MELANIE WARRICK: And
then a coffee break.
KF: Yeah, now I understand that
working involves many things,
such as talking to people.
MARK MANDEL: Right.
KF: When I started out,
I didn't understand this.
And I would just anchor myself
to my computer for eight hours
a day minimum and code things.
And I remember
co-workers would try
to encouraged me to get lunch.
MARK MANDEL: Right, which
is a thing you should do.
KF: You should do this.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
KF: But also, I was entry level.
And it was, like, my first
office, quote, unquote, "job."
MARK MANDEL: Right.
KF: You can't look around
and see other people modeling
how to do things.
So you have to be very
explicit about, like, this
is how I conduct my day.
You could also do it these other
ways, but this is how I do it.
MELANIE WARRICK: How do
you conduct your day?
[LAUGHTER]
KF: So I usually
start working by 9:30,
which means I get up at 9:00
at the earliest, sometimes.
And then I shower and have
breakfast or whatever.
I usually work from
home in the morning,
because I don't like commuting
during rush hour times.
So unless I'm biking, I will
work from home in the morning.
And then I'll take lunch
at around noon to 1:00.
So I'll eat lunch
and then commute
into a co-working space.
And then I will work from the
co-working space for the rest
of the afternoon and then come
home whenever about eight hours
of working has been
accomplished, or until--
sometimes I have a
mindset that I'm in,
and I just don't want to stop.
So I'll keep working until I
finish the thing I'm doing.
MELANIE WARRICK: Adjust later?
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
We've done this remote stuff,
which I actually really enjoy,
because it's something
I used to do too.
I'd love to also hear about, how
do you find good communication
patterns in remote teams?
Things tend to be asynchronous.
Not everyone's awake
at the same time.
Do you have thoughts on either
technology, or patterns,
or workplace standards--
I don't know.
KF: I try to look for
people who enjoy talking.
When I interview, I
try to see if they're
reasonably talkative.
If they have an online
presence, that's
one way to tell if they tend
to talk a lot and stuff online.
Despite working remotely
for the entire time
I've worked in tech, I am
not a very insular person.
And I talk--
[LAUGHING]
MARK MANDEL: Shocked.
KF: You're like--
KF: --shocking.
Shocking, I know.
MELANIE WARRICK: You
might have a few tweets
out there, maybe just a couple.
KF: So I try to find workplaces
where people aren't completely
siloed, and they still
talk to each other
all the time throughout the day.
I comically refer to it as
like, when I start a new job,
I'm joining a new slack.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
And do you feel
like you almost have
to be more vocal in
some ways, being remote?
You kind of have to
push your personality
and your communication
out more than you would,
say, if you're in an office,
because of the distance?
KF: I have experienced
this especially
with people who
are starting out.
And they're relatively junior.
And they are working
remotely for the first time
or something.
If you're in an office and
you have a junior dev who
is struggling, you
can usually tell
that they're struggling,
because they look stressed,
and they haven't
moved for hours,
versus, if they're
remote, you have no idea
unless you constantly
ping them, or unless they
become very direct and tell
you that this is happening,
which is like extremely
unlikely that they
will do this unless you set
up that rapport in advance.
So yes.
MARK MANDEL: And a lot of
GIFs, animated GIFs, I feel,
help a lot.
KF: I use more GIFs
than are reasonable.
MELANIE WARRICK: On
a more general note,
what do you value most in the
companies that you work for?
KF: I try to find people
who are different from me,
who are sufficiently
different from me
that I'm not just
stagnating as a person.
I think a lot of
people look for jobs
where you're picking
up a new tech stack
and pushing yourself
in that regard.
I try to find
companies where they're
open to hiring junior devs,
where not everyone is white,
where not everyone is a
man, where there are queer
people, where there are
people with disabilities,
especially because
if you hire remote,
I feel like a lot of companies
miss the part about how
that kind of
environment can be--
like, when it's
set up correctly,
give people really
great job opportunities.
Because people who are
disabled are generally
deeply unemployed.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
So this is great.
And I just wanted
to say, is there
anything else that you wanted to
talk about around Strange Loop,
around working
remotely, around--
MARK MANDEL: Kubernetes?
Do you want to talk
about Kubernetes?
MELANIE WARRICK: --Kubernetes,
where you're going to be next?
KF: Not particularly.
[LAUGHTER]
MELANIE WARRICK:
That's a good answer.
MARK MANDEL: Well, KF, thank
you for spending time with us
today.
[LAUGHTER]
As always, spending time
with you is a pleasure.
But it was lovely having
you on recording this time.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes, thank
you for coming on the podcast.
Actually, well, one last
thing-- who would you recommend
should consider coming
to Strange Loop?
KF: If you are into
functional programming,
distributed systems,
security-type things,
this is probably a good
conference to go to--
not necessarily like you've done
them or you've been doing them.
But if you were just
interested in them,
I think that's
sufficient to come.
Now let's get dinner.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes.
MARK MANDEL: Let's get dinner.
MELANIE WARRICK:
KF, thank you again
for coming on the podcast.
I'm so glad we were
able to make that work.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, me too.
Really great to have you on.
Actually, I went and had a look.
Melanie, you started
with us in episode 102.
So two more episodes, and
you're at 50 episodes.
MELANIE WARRICK: Sweet,
two more and I'm done.
MARK MANDEL: You were--
MELANIE WARRICK: I'm baked.
MARK MANDEL: You came on to
do "Smart Parking and IoT
Core with Brian Granatir."
We did the wrappers
together for that.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah,
and the Smart Parking
was a really
interesting one too.
I know we resurfaced
that with some articles
that he wrote a while
back-- but yes, good times.
Good times, Mark.
Well, so let's get into
the question of the week--
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: --which is
not about when did I start.
We could have saved that
for the [INAUDIBLE]..
Anyway, so the
question of the week--
how do I encrypt and decrypt
data with Cloud Key Management
Service?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, I think this
is actually really interesting.
I was kind of just
poking around, looking
for a question of the week.
And I've never looked at
Cloud Key Management Service.
But basically, it's a
cloud hosted key management
service that lets you
manage cryptographic keys
for your cloud.
It's actually really cool.
So there's a couple
of posts that we'll
link to about basically doing
encryption and decryption.
I am not a security
expert, so I'm
going to try and read
this as much as possible.
But--
MELANIE WARRICK: It's
like, I'm not a doctor.
MARK MANDEL: I'm not
a doctor, exactly.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
[DING]
- Dr. Mendel, Dr. Mendel, please
report to neurosurgery in OR7.
[END PLAYBACK]
I'm not a lawyer.
I'm none of those things.
But the client APIs as
well as the gcloud tools
support both symmetric
and asymmetric encryption.
So if I get this right,
symmetric algorithms
use the same key for both
encryption and decryption,
whereas asymmetric
algorithms use different keys
for encryption and decryption.
And there are different reasons
for using one over the other.
It's really quite
straightforward
to do the encryption
and decryption.
Basically, you're
specifying your location,
your key ring, your key.
And then you specify the
text you want to encrypt.
And it kind of spits it back.
And then to decrypt it, it's
basically doing the same thing
all over again.
And all of those keys are
managed by Cloud Key Management
Service, which is kind of neat.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes.
MARK MANDEL: And
very similarly, for--
yeah the RSA, the asynchronous
one-- asymmetric--
words are hard--
MELANIE WARRICK:
Some days they are.
MARK MANDEL: --encryption.
And there's also examples
there for different languages
as well--
Go, Java, Python for the
asymmetric, and C#, Go Java,
Node.js, Python, Ruby, PHP.
MELANIE WARRICK: Or just
from your command line.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
you can do it too.
It's actually really
straightforward.
I was super-impressed.
MELANIE WARRICK: Great.
Well, Mark, where are you
going to be in the next couple
weeks, next couple months?
What are you excited about?
MARK MANDEL: That is a
really good question.
I don't think I'm going anywhere
special for the next month,
which is super nice.
Really kind of happy.
It looked like I was
going to go [INAUDIBLE],,
and then I wasn't,
and then I wasn't.
It doesn't look like I'm going.
So it's a little sad.
But I'm sure, plenty of
Google Cloud people there.
They're going to
have a great time.
I think I'm just
excited to be-- yeah,
to be going to
KubeCon in December.
MELANIE WARRICK: Great.
Well--
MARK MANDEL: What
about yourself?
MELANIE WARRICK: This
week, I will be at Canalys
in Washington, DC, which is a
security and data conference.
And I'm looking forward to that.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
Well yeah, actually, the thing
that I will be doing as well
is I will be getting back
into doing some more Twitch
streaming of various things.
MELANIE WARRICK: Oh yeah.
MARK MANDEL: So that
will be lot of fun.
MELANIE WARRICK: Have
you not been doing that?
MARK MANDEL: I took
a break in September,
because I was traveling so much.
MELANIE WARRICK: I was going to
say, clearly, I'm not watching.
MARK MANDEL: But yeah, it'll
good to get back to that.
MELANIE WARRICK: Oh, well good.
I'm glad.
When is that?
MARK MANDEL: Usually I do that
at 9:00 AM Pacific on Tuesdays.
But I'm going to try and slot
in doing some more streams
in the middle of the week.
Follow me on Twitter and
Twitch for more details.
MELANIE WARRICK: And
then, Mark, if people
want to get in touch with us
or subscribe to the podcast--
MARK MANDEL: Oh,
yes, that's good.
We haven't done this in a while.
So if you want to
subscribe to the podcast,
everything can be found
at gcppodcast.com.
You can find our RSS
feeds, the iTunes links.
You can find Stitcher, YouTube,
all the stuff that's on there.
MELANIE WARRICK: Email us
at hello@gcppodcast.com.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, if
you want to send us
questions of the
week, we actually
have a form on the bottom
of the new website.
So if you want to
check that out--
I mean, you can
send us emails too.
Love emails.
Or hit us up on G+, or
hit us up on Reddit.
Our G+ account is +gcppodcast.
Our Reddit is /r/gcppodcast.
MELANIE WARRICK: And we
are gcppodcast on Twitter.
MARK MANDEL: Yep, exactly.
But yeah, if you
go to the website,
and you go all the
way down the bottom,
on the bottom left-hand side
in the footer, there's a form.
You can go there, and you can
drop in questions of the week.
And we check it out
every week to see what
questions people are giving us.
MELANIE WARRICK: What's
on people's minds.
Great, I think that's it
for us for this week, Mark.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
so Melanie, thanks
for joining me for yet
another week on the podcast.
MELANIE WARRICK: Thank you.
MARK MANDEL: Thank
you all for listening,
and we'll see you all next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]